It's normal to expect that
we're always going to,
almost by nature,
actively seek out our own happiness.
Especially in two big areas
of potential satisfaction:
relationships and careers.
So it's odd and
not a little unnerving
to discover just how often
some of us appear to act
as if we were, deliberately,
out to ruin our chances
of getting what we are, on the surface
convinced, that we're really after
When going on dates with
candidates we like the sound of,
we may suddenly lapse
into unnecessary opinionated
or antagonistic behaviour.
"Hello."
"Hi, Ellen, what're you doing friday night?"
"Yes?"
"Who is this?"
"Why, it's Bill, Bill Jenkins."
"Narrator: So Bill didn't do very well."
When we have no difficulty being
charming with the type we aren't so keen on,
Or, in relationships, we may
drive our partners to distraction
through repeated,
unwarranted accusations
or angry explosions.
As if we were somehow willing to
bring on the sad day when,
exhausted and frustrated, our loved ones
would be forced to walk away.
Still sympathetic, but unable
to take so much drama.
And similarly, we could destroy
our chances of promotion at work
when, out of the blue,
after lots of promising years
we get strident with our managers
or, on several occasions, fail to hand in
really important reports in time for meetings.
Such behavior can't be
explained away as mere bad luck.
It deserves a stronger, more intentional term.
This is self-sabotage.
What could possibly explain
such destructiveness?
In large part, how plain ennerving
happiness can sometimes feel to us.
Though happiness is, of course,
what we all fundamentally want,
for many of us, it isn't really
what we know.
We grew up in and
learned to make our peace with
far darker scenarios.
The prospect of hapiness
when it in the end appears
can, therefore, seem
a bit counter intuitive
and not a little bit
frightening.
It isn't what we've come to expect.
And it doesn't feel like home.
We may prefer to choose what's
comfortingly familiar, even if it's difficult,
over what is alienatingly
fulfilling or good.
Getting what we want can feel
unbearably risky.
It puts us at the mercy of fate.
We open ourselves up to hope
and subsequent possibility of loss.
Self-sabotage may leave us sad
but at least safely, blessedly, in control.
It can be useful to keep the
concept of self sabotage in mind
when interpreting our and others
odder behaviour.
We should start to get suspicious
when we catch ourselves
pulling off erratic perfomances
around people we deep down
really like or need to impress.
Furthermore, faced with certain kinds
of viciousness and unreliability in others,
we should dare to imagine the things
are perhaps not quite as they seem.
We might have on our hands
not a nasty, malevolent opponent,
but an almost touchingly
wounded self saboter,
who chiefly deserves
a little patience
and should gently be coaxed
out of doing themselves further harm.
We should come to terms with
and help others to see
just how hard and unnerving
it can sometimes be
to get close to some of
the things we truly want.
If you like our films
take a look at our shop
(Thoughtful books, games stationery and more...)